(tense music)
- [Narrator] From major
retailers to luxury stores
and small businesses,
organized retail crime,
also known as ORC, has been
on the rise for several years,
with a spike in incidents
over the last few weeks.
ORC incidents involve
any form of retail theft
by an organized group, from
shoplifting to cargo theft.
Recently, there has been
a spike in smash and grab
organized retail crime where large groups
smash display windows and can steal
thousands of dollars in
merchandise within minutes.
- I probably saw 50 to 80
people and like ski mask,
crowbars, like a bunch of weapons.
They were looting the
Nordstrom right here.
- [Narrator] Nearly three
fourths of US retailers
said they saw a spike in ORC in 2020,
according to a national
retail security survey.
And many said the pandemic
has played a role.
- As COVID influenced
the way America shops,
everybody was buying their goods online.
So it created this
incredible increase in demand
for online products.
Organized crime organizations stepped up
to fill that demand.
- [Narrator] Ben Dugan
has been following trends
in retail crime for 30 years
and has worked with CVS
for the last four years
to investigate ORC incidents.
He says members of ORC groups can target
as many as 15 to 20 stores in a single day
and often resell the stolen
goods as a third party seller
on various online marketplaces.
- Well, the biggest challenge
when dealing with illicit
sellers on online marketplaces
first and foremost is who they are.
They do not have to provide
their real names or addresses
or banking information or information
that any legitimate
business would provide.
- [Narrator] As CVS
Health's top investigator,
Dugan said he solved 27
cases of e-commerce crime
in 2020 alone, amounting
to nearly $50 million
worth of goods.
Earlier this year, a
bipartisan group of senators
introduced the Informed Consumers Act,
which would require e-commerce platforms
to verify high volume
third-party seller information,
ultimately making it more
difficult to sell stolen goods.
From locking up products and ramping up
physical security measures,
to installing GPS tracking
on products, stores are finding new ways
to combat potential ORC incidents,
specifically smash and grab robberies.
- Retailers are doing a lot,
especially this holiday season.
As always, the number one concern
for the retail community and industry
is to keep our employees
and our customers safe.